-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy- and Tony-nominated
and Academy Award-winning
actor and singer
you know from her work
in "West Side Story,"
"Schmigadoon!",
and "Hamilton" on Broadway.
She stars in the new
animated movie "Wish,"
which is in theaters
nationwide on November 22nd.
Please welcome to the show
Ariana DeBose, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
Hey, y'all! Hi!
-When someone like you,
who knows how to dance,
the way you just walk
is so much --
it makes me so jealous.
When someone like you walks out,
this is how I feel like
I walk out.
-I mean, your timing,
though, is really good.
-Thank you very much.
-Amazing.
-I'm so happy
to have you here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-You have not been in this
building since you hosted
a wonderful episode of "SNL"
in January of '22, I believe?
-I think that's correct, yeah.
-Was it a special time
to be here for that?
-It was.
I mean, why was I hosting "SNL"?
[ Laughs ]
But it was so fun.
And, I mean,
it's such an inherently
theatrical experience.
-Yes.
-It's absolutely insane.
And I don't know why people say
yes to it, but it's so fun.
And I it's funny,
because I feel a little nervy.
Like, you can still feel the
nervous energy in the building.
-I agree.
Like, sometimes for people
who don't, like, come here
every day, they're like,
"Oh, right, there was that very
scary thing down the hall."
-Trauma bond, trauma bond.
But it's so -- I don't know.
It's -- I love the show
And I love this place.
It's iconic.
So anytime you get to be
in the space is great.
-I -- For me, hosting "SNL"
was one of the most
nerve-racking things I ever did.
But I heard you -- And you did
such a wonderful job
hosting the Tonys.
-Oh, thank you.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you. I appreciate that.
Yeah.
-And the timing of that
was also not ideal.
It was right after
the writers' strike.
You very happily received
a waiver from the Guild
to go on with the show,
which was wonderful to support
all the incredible people
and the work they did that year.
-Of course.
-The opening
of the show was a dance number
that was just incredible
to behold.
-Thank you.
-I mean,
the normal dancing stuff,
which you do better
than anyone,
but you also jumped off
the top of the stairs.
-Yes, I did that for Broadway.
-Yes.
-No, that whole number
was kind of --
I mean, of course it was born
of the moment we were in, right?
And, so, I play to my strengths
when I'm in a tight spot.
And I was like, "Cool, we're
going to do a dance overture
and we're going
to celebrate music
to celebrate movement."
And I pulled together a great
team, and we made it happen.
And I have to say, though,
that jump off the stairs wasn't
really rehearsed that way.
-Yeah. Oh, wow.
-No. Like --
-So, who did it different? You?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Like I -- You know --
-Because I should note
that someone caught you,
so I would hope --
That would be the only person
I would think
you'd want to rehearse with.
-Oh, no, of course. But we did.
So, Julius Anthony Rubio
is a dear, dear friend of mine,
and he was one of the dancers
in "West Side Story."
And so when I decided
I was going to
jump down the stairs,
I was like, "Cool, cool.
You gonna catch me."
So...
-Is he, like,
better at catching than most?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I mean, he is -- He's the guy
you want to catch you.
And I had rehearsed
safety first, you know,
so you go up and back, right?
Simple. I had so much adrenaline
in my body, I just said, "Boom!"
-You really did.
-It was --
So, to be perfectly frank,
that moment is kind of
like TV magic,
because I wasn't
supposed to do that.
-Yeah.
-The crazy thing is,
I was watching and I thought,
"God, look at that.
She's probably done
that a thousand times,
and she makes it look
like the first time ever."
-Oh!
-And now I'm finding out,
oh, first time ever.
There you go.
-So fresh. It was so fresh.
-Yeah.
-I definitely --
With the writers on strike,
I watched that incredible
dance overture and I'm like,
"Oh, we don't need
writers, yeah."
-Well -- No, no, no, no.
I love my writers.
Most everything I do --
-I'm joking. I'm joking.
-I know.
But I feel like there
are many writers
who would kill me
if I didn't say this.
And I am here because
of some incredible writers.
Tony Kushner being one of them.
So shout-out, Tony Kushner.
-Yeah, there you go.
Shout-out to Tony Kushner.
-Yeah.
-One of the all time greats.
-You've talked about your mom
many times in the past.
Does she -- I'm assuming
on an evening like the Tonys,
is she there?
Is she supporting you?
Is she going into the parties?
-Well, you know,
this particular year,
this past year,
she was not there.
But, normally, my mom
is my date for everything.
She came to the Oscars.
She was my -- I think
my favorite memory of my mom
is at what I call
the "Hamil-Tony Party."
So it was the year
that "Hamilton"
was honored with
many, many things.
And she literally
was just having the best time.
I looked over, and she was
cutting a rug with Common.
-Oh, wow.
-Like, amazing.
I was like, "Mom,
did you just hit on Common?"
Like -- And then
Mariska Hargitay was,
like, jammin' behind her,
and I was like,
"What is happening?"
But moms and famous people
are the best.
-My mom danced with Idris Elba
once at an Emmy party,
and my dad still
can't watch "The Wire," yeah.
It's too hard for him now.
It's too hard for him.
-But come on.
I mean,
the entertainment industry
is filled with beautiful people,
and so sometimes,
I'm just like,
"Yeah, Mom, go get yours."
-And you know what? Can I say?
I want to give a tip of my cap
to the beautiful people
who every now and then
appreciate the moment.
They're like, "You know what?
I'm going to make someone's mom
feel good right now."
And so I have a very
special place in my heart
for Idris Elba for that moment.
And I feel like Common,
as well, right?
-Absolutely. Shout-out to both.
-Shout-out to both of you.
I have a lot more to ask
about your exciting new film.
We'll be right back
with Ariana after this.